il y un an
la famille al hadath dodge posé ses
valises à montréal chez un oncle
parrainé par leur église et des proches
ils se sont rapidement installés et ont
commencé à chercher un emploi
d'ailleurs travaillé ou aller en cours
de francisation
c'était leur grand dilemme pour compte
il choisit
[Musique]
c'est comme ici sonata vous habite là
les femmes et vos avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as dit n'était pas capable
on change pour la ta mère de famille
comme l'année passée c'est se passe très
très bien
félicitations parce que moi lorsque
j'aurais été capable de faire ça
travailler 15 heures dans une journée
qu'après ça allait étudier le lendemain
qui ont commencé à être indépendant moi
je dirais en trois et quatre mois mois
date où tous les exemples que j'ai sont
vraiment des des exemples de succès l'a
constaté ça n'a pas ce que je fais je
suis fier de ça va aller chez la famille
je pense qu'est ce qu'ils veulent et
c'est youssef zouini avec sa femme
gracia et les deux enfants deux garçons
georges et jean bellini et avec la maman
de youssef qui s'appelle jacqueline
kabako là ça m'a fait plaisir comme
j'étais capable d'aider ces sortes de
familles qui étaient dans le dans le
danger et ils sont maintenant ici et
commence à commencer d'avancé dans les
langues française travail est fait les
efforts pour vivre dans leur
gouvernement ainsi pour être dans le
culte québécois dans la société tout ça
va
fin de la journée
[Musique]
en fait ce que
clay les draps
en voilage lecaussin
comme ça
[Musique]
bein je tarde à l'aide d'un nouveau pari
de la cheville
au bas de gamme chan
vachon
dans l'état régional de rhénanie
[Musique]
jeudi à l'annoncé rodas mécanicienne la
scénario
montez barre
je n'avais pas par exemple accès vous
aide du gouvernement seydou qu'on avait
parrainé c'est à dire lorsque j'ai dis
nous c'est notre organisme
notre église devrait verser n'importe
quelle somme qui est versée par le
gouvernement se dit le bien être social
ou quoi que ce soit donc à ce moment là
ces gens là ils ont quand même été
décrété au courant était conscient comme
ils doivent trouver un travail le plus
vite possible dans ce qui est plus
facile ou le parrainage privé parce
qu'il ya toujours une planification d'
avance s'il ya une communauté qui
s'engage envers tes un groupe de
personnes qui arrivent ici qui se
mobilisent famille qui rentrait en avez
l'occasion de défendre ces personnes là
ont les ont déjà embauché si on a pensé
on va les aider à s'intégrer aussi en
même temps ils travaillent avec leurs
collègues le collègue est pas le
français axa va le mettre plus dans le
simple canadien et être plus à l'aise à
travailler et être plus à l'aise à
s'intégrer et s'intégrer surtout plus
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui parce qu'avec une route très
bel honneur de l'amour
au bas des deux équipes d'enseignants il
a directement de cours à tous challans
nico bulgare darik baradei madame pas
les français
je vais mettre ma dodge oued el ma
banque la badoit chaîne ab3 faire amener
nardella de la barre 1
fini car a fini comme ça libère
on aimerait à terme neutre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
bah
et quentin
avec
promis on amène soutine criaient dans ma
bande
et les vidéos
la cible de relever d'un canon fille
espèces menacées intissar
neymar chez nous on a l'air pendant
contrées comme dans l'amérique this
chaque tombe chaque dimanche on se
trouve
nous mêmes dans la même église
ça donne ici on a fait la même habitude
c'est notre petit morceau ce il ya
beaucoup de sentiments quand tu fais un
si petit trou où les sentiments tout
beaucoup de choses vous êtes heureuse
aujourd'hui parce que je sais pourquoi
mais je ne trouve pas les mêmes chiffres
mais cela s'est toujours être liés au
web disons à la communauté syriaque et
même à la communauté d'autres églises
aussi avec moi je les encourage tout
délit un petit peu plus loin que ça
c'est des joueurs qui restent à leurs
cookies qui est dans leurs ghettos parce
que sinon ces risques comme quoi qui
vont pas penser qu'ils vont pas être
lieu parce que le travail qu'ils font
mais temporairement
ils vont ils sont en train de le faire
les choses pour qu'ils puissent vivre
mais plus tard ils ont certainement des
rêves
ici on pas là disons si dans le temps
dans le futur y ont pas cette maîtrise
de la langue française
ça va être un défaut pour le sait sans
jouer ça n'a pas trop le temps de
maîtriser le français
priorité au travail pour les parents un
jour peut-être
ils retourneront en visite en syrie mais
probablement sans leur fils qui risque
de devoir y faire leur service militaire
leur souhaite la paix en syrie
[Musique]